[Music]
what you're seeing with the taliban in
control of afghanistan is increasingly a
failed state
we're going to continually be confronted
with the consequences of this disorder
chaos and instability misgovernments
you know what happens in afghanistan
will not stay in afghanistan
it inevitably will bleed out into
the world in ways that are unpredictable
and most likely dangerous and harmful to
all of us
[Music]
i think afghanistan is poised to become
a real petri dish for terrorist
organizations
at a minimum their inability to control
or unwillingness to control those groups
that has implications not just inside
afghanistan but for all of its neighbors
a year ago
when the taliban took over afghanistan
in the wake of the calamitous u.s
withdrawal there was a lot of concern
that the taliban would be back to their
old tricks namely providing sanctuary to
al-qaeda what we learned this month is
that's exactly what they've been doing
as feared
the fact that emmanuel zawahiri the
al-qaeda leader
was living more or less openly in the
taliban's capital is proof positive that
al qaeda is on the rebound in
afghanistan he's not going to be the
only one
if the leader felt safe there that his
followers certainly felt safe there as
well
and we also know that their objectives
their intentions are to hit the united
states wherever they can
our embassies abroad our military abroad
and our homeland
but there will also be plotting attacks
against american allies around the world
allies like israel allies like the
united kingdom like our european
partners
americans should care about terrorism in
afghanistan because that's how we got
911. the taliban provided sanctuary to
osama bin laden and his al-qaeda
terrorists for the years leading up to 9
11 that produced a wave of terror
attacks against the united states
but it's not just al qaeda that finds
fertile soil in afghanistan isis has a
very active affiliate in afghanistan
that was responsible for a horrific
suicide attack
at the airport in kabul during the u.s
evacuation that killed a number of
american service members as well as a
number of innocent afghans trying to
flee taliban rule
it's an increasingly unstable situation
in an already unstable region
you have china going in and being very
opportunistic in this situation
to lock down rare earth supplies and
mines and also
russia willing to support the taliban
for their own domestic political
reasons
historically when there's conflict and
instability in afghanistan you see
explosion of the opium and heroin trade
out of afghanistan this has huge
implications not just for europe which
is the primary market for that poverty
but also for the global market
if a flood into the market decreases the
price in europe it's going to have an
impact on the price of opioids here in
the united states
when the price for heroin drops it means
that it is more widely available more
accessible
the taliban is completely incapable of
managing the territory of afghanistan
it's incapable of meeting the basic
needs of the citizens of afghanistan
which is going to precipitate worse
humanitarian crises more disorder more
problems in that country leading to
refugee flows
the previous democratic government of
afghanistan was not perfect by any
stretch of the imagination
but at least it was trying at least it
provided basic protections for human
rights at least it tried to provide the
rule of law for its citizens
but all of that has been washed away by
the taliban wave
it certainly takes the pressure off of
countries like pakistan that do not have
a good record on women's rights who do
not have a good record on on human
rights overall on tolerance for other
religious groups especially religious
minorities such as christians
if you have a country that's next door
to you that is is really at the bottom
of the barrel on human rights it of
course is going to take some of the
attention off of your
less than attractive features when it
comes to human rights
allowing problems like this to fester
has never worked out well for us
you